Sonique dead in the sport and Rob's his
backs off with all the information he
doesn't play off the back of it he tries
to help his team out on B but it's too
little and too late fer has done a
massive job ten seconds left Rob's has
to hold on to his chick in blocking the
door
I've not seen that before that gets him
killed oh my god
a chicken bak in the door just got Rob's
killed guys in csgo there are certain
known quantities like if someone calls
rush B don't stop and you stop you will
die if you smoke a Molly it should
extinguish you see those things decent
ascender old bug CS goes and its finest
yep and if you drop a smoke and Stewie
two K's in the server well he's gonna
push it whoso slips in behind the
forklift it gets away with it get back
to the site and finds fallen as well
bomb goes down he's unrelenting pushing
through the smoke line and they're gonna
have no idea what this hop is Stewie
brilliant but sometimes you just see
some [ __ ] that makes you want to say
Peter to decide Oh No that's why this
week on best stuff we're taking a look
at the weirdest and honestly dumbest
ways to die in csgo that we've seen so
far now these include straight-up bugs
crazy needs that frankly should never
happen and of course team and self kills
leaning back in Stewie's looking for it
more bullets
the wrong move it's time aw p3k clutch
knows what freezes and will transport
them out with the AWP pop flash coming
out the ball top of push freeze away -
smoke
that she'll and oh my god the smoke bug
packs overing goose and he watching from
the crossroads 25 seconds on the clock
and Chris Jays already down into CT
spawn candy didn't spy of Apex he's just
gonna get burnt out over in the back of
the site and uh yeah thanks just
watching the flames there at that point
this is fine I'm okay with the events
that are unfolding currently really sure
what do you think was gonna happen um
can we find out what happened to merge
possibly most destroying the CT side as
well I don't
okay so far so good everything is going
according to plan
nice yes good smut we have a kill but I
have no idea never get a team liquid
looking for a way and through a main but
it's so slow it's just like a snail's
pace now and c9 if so much utilities
still toss back inside of a man just to
hold these players back another days
gonna roll in almost takes down Sifl
about five more HP off of them and
unfortunate just gonna walk around at
that luckily so you actually got rut
boosted over the edge burned in like
midair I don't even know but pretty
pretty funny to watch
sunny dead in the sport and roxas backs
off with all the information he doesn't
play off the back of it tries to help
his team out or be but it's too little
with too late fur has done a massive job
ten seconds left robs has to hold onto
it
chick in blocking the door I've not seen
that for that gets him killed
oh my god a chicken Bock of the dogs got
robbed still some damage done but Alex
can just stay safe now he has to peek
was the bomb calyx again playing the
time dozy hasta push the spray comes in
gets the kit as well I think those
adjustable has it what it goes like on
an invisible wall oh my god is that big
yeah I think he hit off like it a little
bit of the wall that comes out and if he
hits the headshot perfect situation
because we just can win it from where he
is if he's not spotted down he goes he
spotted up by bialy that's the shot he
needed snacks gets it they don't know
miss just gets here we didn't think that
goat that deep in stolen and Australis a
tip to win I have to go now my planet
needs me
well guys those plays if you can call
them that will have you scratching your
head but in this next section we're
gonna look at pro player deaths that
come by way of their own team now you
know when this [ __ ] happens the comms
are lit up with calls of what the [ __ ]
so [ __ ]
delicious - tequila Jenelle
he knows automatic was at Hut at some
point and starts creeping on up trying
to get the information where is this
player 40 seconds out there in trouble
they've got no smokes here to lure them
out anyway
maybe liquid just didn't even need gonna
be defeated to decide oh no is going on
is that a form of surrender to please I
want to fly this map anymore
I don't want to live on this planet
anymore I just made his way out but the
other two are still just emerging right
now oh no smear well he's got to kill at
least now he's got to cut the font we're
going down the force he can really hard
to pop in that situation and this media
will make up for it by pretty much
taking out everybody else
very easy addition to your Pug
repertoire which makes life I did missus
estimate the phase by coming in around
sooner than I thought my bad but phase
lets protractors down more calculator
yeah I should get on the calculator I'd
very intelligent Neko stepping up with
us honest us be able weapons the bomb
would not work laughter they all gets
lost in the smoke Canada nya he can it
goes down but all my sister where the
fact oh cool DT no talk going the
Smokies got confused he lost track and
the fact that the palm actually went
down and had to change the plant man
Olaf lost track of it but now he's got a
chance back into it oh my goodness
I'm gonna say Olaf is the type of player
you'd expect him to just hold that down
that cold makes no mistake the second
time around that cut awkward to kill the
AWP there
fair enough they got very very scrappy
asleep Oh with the shyness USP business
was as much confusion or just chaos I do
wonder if they reworked that strap
you know have they had the time to go
back through it you know right simple
into as an individual easy oh my god
what is just leave a ball season but
Neos already going over towards B so I
don't I don't think this is that fourth
amendment first being sold a kipper here
as his fallen as his taco they still
need to sacrifice someone on make a play
happen but burn taco taco dome he's
gonna have a transfer out into the halls
misses his spray versus speedy but
markeloff now the anchor Nikko kills
Chris Jane so two on to and what is that
spinning with the 180 shuts down
markeloff six seconds left could they
get the ball plant not gonna happen
world that it's gonna drop speedy and
this is it they're actually gonna win on
time I feel horrible we shooting at
someone suffering like this we shouldn't
be laughing just this extremely painful
well guys we've seen deadly falls team
kills and of course death by nade and
I'm not talking about the kind that
actually explode but in this next
section we're gonna be looking at the
most tilting of them all and talking
about self kills the bomb outside and Oh
simple
and he goes down and if it has getting
wallbang then putting some [ __ ] no
summit I hope you're watching the game
brother they too have the Molly but as
you can see he just threw down the smoke
so he's actually gonna try to paint this
the Molly immediately goes down the
players push back out rush was hoping
someone would push down ramp I think
that he jumped on the defuse they're
right about that they did get him out
there the wrong spot he's just trying to
maximize damage now he's gonna go in
he'll jump onto this team might have
just enough time cajon he's gonna
finally will get around go for a French
megabyte mp9 before venturing in towards
upper tunnels and then the one UMP on
rain who is aware of the meta my
favorite yeah oh are you okay you look
so great suddenly things are looking
very bad I see the full damage oh my god
that could have been an ace but by the
Ford of it so is that was know if
anything that was the best ace I've ever
seen look give your center for I don't
think I miss what you think it means
yeah it doesn't feel like they're really
just gonna die with the bottom I don't
want to give a chance for seconds look
it up this is quite amusing the wall
they threw all the guns over the wall
odd start with another turned into the
one versus one and still has that
incendiary gonna look to try and force
around and wins the one be one as well
or shall be saved
oh my god the ultimate one gee I'm out I
am al why do people didn't call it laid
out
no but a crazy stuff I mix all their
mile XMS cross this bomb back towards
spawn it's happy to fall to his death
happy jumping headfirst for halos this
[ __ ] sounds gonna get it done what
around from misfits and what a mistake
from happy they can't even explain that
oh we missed the ladder well guys that's
it for best of this week now if you want
to see more content just like this you
already know what to do
Molly to subscribe button let the flames
spread to the like button and consider
nating the comment section and I will
see you next time thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]